I want to see a Will Smith biopic played
by Will Smith and his focus on his
relationship with Jada Will Smith Bob
pick played by August he get cucked out
right now why like that that's [__] up
dude that's [__] up oh that's too soon
dude take that back
[Music]
so if you guys remember recently
um there was a Bruce Lee moment in
Hollywood where Bruce Lee was in Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood oh yeah and now
Ang Lee famous director Crouching Tiger
he's going to make a Bruce Lee biopic oh
yeah I'm so sick you know who's gonna be
Bruce Lee though who his son
is this Bruce Lee the child story
no this is Bruce Lee Bruce Lee has a
five-year-old for the whole movie his
son's not gonna his son's not that young
oh it's a biopic do you have a photo of
his son he doesn't look like him but
that might make it better well the thing
is when you do like a Bruce Lee or a
Michael Jackson like two of the most
Wiggly squigglers in the world it's
Unique though
it's [__] hard to mimic that kind of
movement
ironically though there's like
um they're so signature in their
movement that it's mimics so well across
the world I've never seen anyone mimic
it well
what about that little Japanese kid
Bruce was different that little Japanese
kid he's good for a kid but like an
adult-sized man I've never seen anyone
like move as good well for sure nobody
can move like Bruce that's like also
what made him what but it has to be
close yeah the new Watcher you're just
like oh this guy's slow it has to do
with Justice that's all I think I'm not
a fan you have a Mike Tyson biopic and
this guy is not scary you're like oh
yeah you gotta be intimidating wasn't
there Mike Tyson he was scary didn't
Bruce uh just to carry my game over that
I always do that Bruce Lee wasn't that
good
didn't Bruce not ever compete as a
fighter dude he he was undefeated in
street fights I'm just about movement
he's fast as [__] it's just hard he
looks like a whip he revolutionized
Martial Arts Cinema okay some say that
he made it into kind of a joke Amanda
parody everyone else did it wasn't
everybody wanting to copy him and then
it was the derivatives of them yeah
exactly why did you gotta go whoa and
let the enemy know that you're coming
because that's how good how come you
don't like Bruce she's like Part White
[Laughter]
actually I know why Steve doesn't like
Bruce Lee because Bruce Lee was stealing
white women dude did he marry white
chick Linda Linda Lee but he's Part
White yeah I got eighth or something
recorder or a quarter maybe I didn't do
something I liked about the fellow
yeah
180s that was such a good one oh well to
me it's absurd to uh you can't I mean
he's such an icon like the real the real
question is is Ang Lee's son gonna be
able to top the Bruce Lee from Shaolin
Soccer
in terms of looks he's probably the
closest he's the sick as the goalie come
on
so good well I mean what would you guys
want to see because I I think honestly
like that scene in Once Upon a Time I
could have followed that character the
rest of the movie honestly so he was
really good he was so good he was very
good as Bruce the way he's like I
thought so I thought he sucked I thought
he was great what do you like about it
let me suck that you wanted to be faster
let me guess you wanted to be faster
yeah faster because he flew up what
would be wiggle better he's a little he
was skinnier what kind of uh tone what
you want like more action briefly or
more like uh like Joker where it's dark
and that you you hear is like inner
thoughts like what kind of Bruce Lee
movie I like an under a more understated
Bruce Lee yeah I want a Will Ferrell
Bruce Lee there it is that's good like a
Leslie Chow Bruce Lee oh that'd be fire
that'd be really good dude what would
have been great as if they got David
Carradine's son to play Oh Bruce Lee you
know I'll [__] that is you know how [__]
that is yeah because he was so David
Carradine yeah is a white actor who is
cast
um in kung fu and it pissed Bruce Lee
off to no end uh because that was a
Bruce Lee star yeah he was supposed to
be he was supposed to be the starring
actor but you know how it came back in
the 90s as the Kung Fu Legend Continues
and then his his son well the guy that
played his son was like a cop and then
David Carradine was the dad yeah I used
to watch that series I used to watch it
too I watched it too I thought it was
amazing yeah me too I didn't know that
he was a child he was supposed to be
Chinese I had no idea oh you thought he
was just mystical white guy I just
thought it was a like because at the
time there were a lot of white guys
doing karate his rated not a mystical
white guy yeah he's a mystical
he mostly white yeah is Gandalf not a
mystical white guy there it is uh um
yeah you're right he's very mystical
he's probably the most mystery he didn't
I didn't know until later on he was
playing a Chinese dude and I don't know
The Legend Continues and then later I I
found out the Kung Fu series
to get just back on what you were saying
though I would like a an understated and
darker tone Bruce Lee biopic I love that
yeah absolutely more realistic yeah just
one that doesn't have to talk as much
but it's more like action based and yeah
all of that or like less less dialogue I
think but like what what's the story
what's the lens of Bruce Lee's story
that you would want to watch is the main
that's the real one the real oh the
actual real life yeah like him his his
like like a biopic like him being a
troublemaker and then finding passion in
martial arts yeah and and strong in his
struggles in Hollywood low-key though
Jason Scott Lee in the dragon that movie
is pretty fire too that movie six five
because he's pretty good dragons to me
the most interesting thing about Bruce
Lee was is that yes he wasn't a
competition fighter but he was fighting
the whole [__] time behind the scenes
and that's the coolest part that's the
real competition well he revolutionizes
the gank exactly so I'm a big fan yeah
he's my guy he's my North Star you know
what about
um so if they do the life story thing do
you want them to put in
the truth behind how he died you know
how he like isn't that a mystery still
kind of I mean it's like debatable but
one thing that I don't know if it's true
but like how he was like cheating on his
wife at the end so he has another kid no
like he he like when he went into
cardiac or whatever he was like with a
mistress at the time I thought he was
with Chuck Norris the day before working
out like a [__] and then the
next day he died maybe but I think he
was on the set of Enter the Dragon he
was at the house of that like one
actress yeah yeah yeah it was holler but
then like the wife kind of maintains it
he wasn't cheating so it's kind of weird
just keep it honorable or whatever yeah
a little bit we want the truth but then
yeah like what do you want in the
morning there was also I think he was
dabbling in a bunch of like substances
which was a very experimental guy oh so
they're saying something some of it
could have been laced too to be fair
though if you're saying Ang Lee's doing
it like I'm not expecting any of that
[__] oh yeah I'm like expecting Aang to
do an angry movie he's probably gonna a
Crouching Tiger it yeah with Bruce Lee
flying in the sky with a [__] Dragon
which I'm not mad at because that's what
we're two gay cowboys yeah or he might
Hulk it
Hulk remember Hulk where you do the
whole thing he did the Edward Norton one
or the Eric Bana one the banner one oh
that's right that what else was it bad I
didn't see that one do you remember it
that was the first one right before it's
pretty bad it was bad
the technology was not as good what's
the last hitter Angley did the last like
all right black pie was huge what if my
fight was great that's the last one
life of why was amazing but that's a
long time ago though that was a long
time ago yeah are you sure maybe there
might be another one you know what
anglia's versatile but he only makes
masterpieces though that's true that's
true he makes what he wants right that's
nice dude talk about life up higher than
Crouching Tiger this is my [__] don't
[__] around I mean the whole thing was
[__] around
let me see he better bring back Mr
Peters the [__] tiger Richard Peters
Richard Petersburg Gemini man oh that
was terrible oh oh and that's angry oh
boys it's not looking good that's what
Will Smith was like that's not good
fighting himself right that's what he
had Will Smith and angry and it still
sucks what about Billy's Billy Lynn's
long halftime walk do you guys remember
that one I did it do you remember that
one yeah dude
Blockbuster hit her dude the idea of
Will Smith the idea of selling Will
Smith the movie be like hey you're gonna
fight your younger self he's like a man
wait that sucked
dude I think the last couple movies that
Will Smith has done nobody was like uh
except for uh King Richard
like that [__] was that good I didn't
see it but I heard he wanted a [__]
Oscar for it yeah and he slapped the guy
before you know except some Rando dude I
want to see a Will Smith biopic played
by Will Smith and his focus on his
relationship with Jada
that'd be pretty cool dude we already
know what that relationship Will Smith
Bob pick played by August he's getting
cucked out right now why like that
that's [__] up dude that's [__] up
oh that's too soon dude take that back
so you know that scene of uh Bruce Lee
out once upon a time that that was
rooted in Industry people saw Bruce Lee
because my friend's Grandpa would um
he's in that same circle of like Chuck
Norris and his brother and all them so
Chuck Norris's brother was an actual
fighter he was a kickboxer he did all
that stuff and his group was like the
guys that basically were at the
Forefront of martial arts and kickboxing
in America truck was one too right he
was a real fighter yeah he's a real
fighter too Chuck Norris day well
according to what my friend says he was
the Hollywood guy the reason why he went
toward that way is because he understood
it but like he wasn't much of a real
fighter like he wasn't like into it into
it like the way that his brother was
okay so then he was more like the action
fighting guy and like on camera but like
he didn't want to compete as hard and
and then so he went two different
directions and so like they hung out in
that same circle with Bruce Lee and
whatever and then so Bruce Lee was
around kickboxers Bruce Lee never fought
but he acted like he did and so that was
the inside joke I guess of the Once Upon
a Time thing where like he would go up
and he would challenge people and
everyone's like dude like
dude they're not gonna take you serious
you're like the short dude and this
guy's like six something and you're just
trying to bully him and so there were
these scenes that were always happening
like on set where he would like try to
bully people and that's the rumor and
then I think that's so inside baseball
that the outside world doesn't [__]
know this [__] and then so I've heard it
from rumors of people that were in like
that scene or like they had a close
proximity to it because all the stories
that we hear a lot of the times are like
from the followers of Bruce Lee and
Bruce Lee himself so if we want to be
objective with it we don't know how
truth Clinton Tarantino has said in an
interview that he wrote that scene based
off of a book that was written by
another person about Bruce Lee see
there's a lot of weird stuff and then
the guy who wrote the book said you
misunderstood what I wrote oh yeah
he's like ah [__] because everyone was
pissed that you know everyone was mad
like Quentin tarantine I wrote him that
way yeah but quentinian was like no like
I got it from this is my source there's
like like an interview where he really
excited yeah and then the writer's like
that's not what I'm saying like yeah
yeah so the writer was you know his I
don't know but it wasn't like he said I
didn't mean it like that like it wasn't
that way yeah he's like I meant he got
his ass to be way harder
you throw it through the windshield
cleaned his [__] clock and the car
was Brown by the way but then that might
be that might have just been the only uh
maybe like there's a lot of sources like
that but they probably don't want to be
named they don't want to be like the
person he is someone that's hard to diss
because amongst even real Fighters he's
considered the father of MMA yeah like
even Dana White said it himself so it's
like if you [__] on someone like that
it's like you're pissing off yeah
everybody everybody and he's so iconic
man yeah he elevated that Martial Arts
Cinema to a whole other level and then
obviously Jackie and Samo and all those
guys to go to the oh next time yeah yeah
yeah but the Hulk
foreign
[Music]